we've more to do with each other in
every film in the past what am I seeing
we had more to do with each other right
so first it was more to do with each
other with it filming of classic
fastness films and manic happiness did
give me in first class we get to see
Eric basically hunting down Nazis and in
doing so cross paths with Charles he's
filled with a lot of rage and we know
his his history as a child it's pretty
traumatic so he carries that with him
Charles helps him sort of access his
full powers by controlling that rage
letting go of it and thus sort of
unleashes magneto by the end of first
class Erik inadvertently paralyzes
Charles lamented I didn't and so you
know creates professor X in the second
film we get to see Erik as a prisoner
and a terrorist in the third film we get
to see him as a family man and he's just
trying to lead a normal life that gets
destroyed by humans again again and then
in this film he's kind of I guess the
most content we've seen him outside of
his family life he's pretty much a loner
his best friend is Charles you know his
only friend in a way and he's kind of
reached this point where he's made this
compromise he has Kenosha has this place
but he's pulled out of there in this
episode by the death of a friend that he
feels like he needs to avenge she's very
old testament when it comes to things
like that he believes for even an eye
for an eye and tooth for tooth we've
been lucky enough like Michael didn't
seem to take on a big journey or for
films from I canna self-interested small
world view
student who likes using his tricks to
get ladies meets his best friend they'll
ever have and this guy Eric magneto sort
of changes him forever and gave him a
hell of a lot of pain and angst and
anxiety and trauma that he never had
until he met him and sure doing what all
good friends are all good friends are
for and would you be my best man and in
so doing can it helps create Professor X
and then we get to watch him go through
the mill and Days of Future past where
he's he doesn't believe this thing that
he's always believed the thing that
defines and really is that he believes
that it's good and everyone that is
always hope he loses that and he has to
find that again and there's a future
past and then in Apocalypse you see him
as this this guidance counselor teacher
type figure and then to this film where
we get to see him as a politician was a
huge deal live political platform when
he's trying to sale the message of
integration which is a great message but
I think he's taking his eye off the ball
and he's not really applying that
attention in that love and that hope
which is always defined him at home he's
out there just trying to become the next
president of the world it seems
I think Charles is always looking for
people to fix
he loves ed massively one of the things
that appeals them in the relationship is
that he was able to help you he was able
to sort over they gave you something and
as much as that's generous and nice it
still puts it let's Charles be in a
position and his mind which is sort of
in charge or have some kind of moral
authority even but it's not until the
last movie what I think Charles realizes
that he's just that's been a such a
fallacy of all his life that he had any
kind of moral authority just because he
was able to help anybody and we find
these two at the end of this from a very
different sweatshop relationship and hmm
where I think if we ever went forward
Charles more than anything else I think
what drew me to this saga originally was
the fact that you know was born out of
the civil rights era and we've always
looked at these two characters is like
Malcolm X being Eric and Martin Luther
King jr. for Charles and the fact that
both of these characters want a better
future for their people
and they just have very different
ideologies about how to get that Charles
believes in integration and Eric
believes in protecting their own looking
after themselves and if segregating
themselves from humans means the best
way to protect themselves then so be it
and if it means going to war with them
and you know so be it as well and I
think the relationship is interdependent
I don't know if you guys have two rival
football teams that live in the same
city maybe I mean certainly my Celtic
and excite without one or the other in
this league and fighting one another
they kind of and we've had that exact
scenario Rangers that these two teams in
Glasgow the if straddle the religious
divide I said sectarian divide for over
a hundred and twenty odd years and we
did have this nunnery were one of them
disappeared Rangers were relegated to
the Bolton leaving for five or six years
we were without each other and it was
heavy stuff it's been I'm really glad
they're back as much as we there's so
much animosity between the teams of
yours that would floundered over there
yeah you're right is similar to that
yeah very excited but that loud you know
yeah don't know what you can tell it was
important to show that those origins
were in a very different place from
their destination otherwise what's the
point in going back if something's just
the same as they were 40 years later
like maybe they don't deserve their own
story so it was important to take the
elements that Patrick portrayed so
brilliantly like his selflessness his
empathy his zen-like quality and then do
the opposite of all those things making
me a little bit selfish make him a
little bit flippant make him vain make
him boisterous make him all these things
and then over the course of four movies
you you realize that your final
destination is much more in a similar
place to what Patrick was doing but
trying to get there in an interesting
and rewarding way and not just like
doing it on the second film well I
didn't bother you know doing IANS voice
in the first one which I had did just
for the second one because he's in in
the movie with me so that I guess was
like I remember I had the conversation
with Matthew Vaughn I was like okay
should I should I do
him and Karen's voice should I bring
that in he was like oh you was kind of
weird and so let's go with that
my okay is that a compliment I like to
what you brought to because it was quiet
like a cannot I this version of
something like Sean Connery we bond and
you were quite the sort of international
man of mystery then I saw spike and a
figure in first class sad to see it go
the same yeah me too I tried to get in
to do my voice you [ __ ] out before
happens
[Music]
we saved my life so thank you for that
that's cool I mean you know I don't like
to mention it all the time that that is
a nice moment where I don't know exactly
what you said but you do see something
along the lines of like I thought I was
alone I thought I'd only one and I see
something like you'll never be alone
again or or like or just I love you I
thought I'm so long you know and but
it's a really beautiful moment
and there's a lot more than first class
if you're like the height the peak of
sort of body nose yeah like when you
when you move the radio antenna is a
pretty euphoric moment I see remember
yeah I believe that true focus lies
somewhere between rage and serenity the
darkest moment hmm I suppose you broke
me out of prison and then I just sort of
let loose yeah you destroyed I think
you're trying to destroy the White House
little bit boss Stadium yeah yeah was
that dark though or just like we're just
over the hill that dog is a bit much
yeah it seemed like the most weirdly
mundane and yet most upsetting moment
for Charles is in this film where he
goes and he goes out sharp as always a
speech and it's just like you're like oh
I think you've hurt me the way that only
my your wife had something like a really
good thing and you're like yeah I know
same thing you've been saying for ten
years man shut it you like ah yeah that
was strangely actually the most cutting
moment Charles I can't let you go in
there you're always sorry Charles
and there's always a speech
well nobody cares anymore you know what
we had more to do together in first
class and there's a future past less
soon there's a future prospect in the
next movie there was less to do and
apocalypse there was less to do until
finally there was - that was in this
movie scene like three words to each
other yeah so that's how it's changed
massively we don't get to do it I think
it's a great travesty and one of the
great mr. opportunities of this
incarnation of the x-men saga agreed we
do get to play a game of chess in this
we do we do you know we come full circle
and have a we inspiration you have the
first movie I quite like the plane scene
in this first where you freak out on me
and you're like oh you've abandoned your
people yeah yeah a dingo took my baby
quite like that scene and you make the
airplane go crazy and we all nearly died
cuz you're angry and where that goes
that that whole scene it was like
Charles is getting a bit like oh well
have a better you don't sure you of
course he's not got the magnetic ability
but I want to pick all that [ __ ] up
I like the scene and it's pretty simple
scene where I go to leave the mansion in
the dead of night
Oh in first class yeah that we had that
we meet when we're rewriting that scene
quite a bit more material for first
class no no I mean Jane did a fantastic
job she did do a yeah but there was a
little vinegar that's it yeah yeah I
think we've had the chance to do that
actually and all of them you know
yeah I'm Simon going to let us sort of
tinker around with them serve vite say
yes can I welcome to Oz anyone kind of
goes they all right what do you think
what do you want to add what you want to
take away and then if we come up with a
bad idea of course be like no but I'm
he's been very inclusive isn't he
generous definitely and he's material I
did meet him at comic-con um when we
were promoting Days of Future past that
was a great privilege um I don't know
what we talked about cuz I was just sort
of in one of those moments like okay you
know where you're not listening you're
just sort of I think this is a legend in
front of me so I can't remember the
conversation we had but it was it
obviously great privilege I remember
having the same reaction that I've had a
few writer creators the that I've made
one have worked on their material on
sort of helped sort of bring it to
live-action just being hugely nervous
because I don't want them to go that
uh-huh you know it's interesting
Oh casting against type are we which
I've had one right or do to me before
really yeah yeah I won't
I won't call him because he's a nice man
I had a man with a writer - oh really no
he was really sweet it was really nice
and I mean you know mines helped create
an empire of them
and that's something that was always
thinking right that's actually something
that stays with me how how sweet a man
anyway you know it's such a nice energy
of arms such as like a positive it yeah
is really generous there's a great line
in Braveheart from the late actor great
actor Ian Bannon who said to Robert the
Bruce when he said when he's trying
costing him and say don't go off and
fight with you anymore
right even though it's the right thing
to do don't go and do it he says it's
really easy to like him isn't it because
uncompromised uncompromising man not
easy to like and it's true like Eric's
so uncompromising it's like you're drawn
to him but also he's always right as
well
Humana he released I was in the back he
says and often and they do they always
do so I think I would go Alec god it's a
I mean I think I'm gonna go with Charles
just because I think in order to move
forward you have to integrate and that's
just because of that alone I would have
to stick with his ideology
[Music]